maybe they were hungry that day they
were drawing it out i'm very hungry why
am i not having lunch yet ah is there
somebody from a transformers used to
think the master like a pizza said you
know i want to make it the biggest ship
but on that cybertron and mine is a
unicron a piece of pizza
[Music]
and this is
the global unboxing first ever in the
world that we know of
of
the arc from transformers
the warren cybertron trilogy and of
course from the g1 series
this is the ship that brought the
autobots from cybertron to earth
and now thanks to hasbro it's now a
transformer
we're going to transform it we're going
to show you what's inside all that great
stuff but first let's talk about the
packaging we've got beautiful artwork on
the front
all right and as we turn this around
you've got the arc mainframe teletran
one and something underneath this hand
which i don't want to show you
just yet a little bit of a surprise
but that is what's inside of this box
and it is
it's pretty hefty anyway
now let's
take it out and see what it's all about
[Applause]
so we've got the ark in front of us out
of the box and as zach i'm calling luigi
said
this looks like a piece of pizza when
you look at it huh this is a nice
triangle the color is about the same
like a cheese of pizza but you got the
olives you got the pineapple a little
bit of pepperoni the pizza
something to think about
anyway
it is what it is
but this is the ark
these are the uh
fire bursts that go outside the back of
it
doesn't stick on that well
i'll show you why in just a bit
so i'm taking it off for the sake of
this review
but let's talk about my first
impressions of the arc i feel like
gerald right now caressing the arc watch
our unicron video if you know what i'm
talking about if you know you know
anyway
this is
a very hefty piece of uh
transformer man this is heavy i mean if
you're a little kid good luck i mean
they said this is for adults but you
know come on it's still the animation
show kids are watching this kids are
gonna be like mommy daddy i want the ark
noah's ark no the ark there's gonna be a
lot of explaining going on in school
kids trust me but
the cybertronian arc
i'm with you on that one but it's really
hefty um very robust
so you got the stands here on the bottom
of it then if you want you can actually
press these buttons
and then your autobots can come up and
down from here
so i'm going to transform this
uh probably with the help of many people
here at geek culture to be honest with
you guys it's been a number of years
since i've transformed a transformer
i have the original g1 series
this gray in my beard should signify
yeah
og
now they say it's 26 steps
how easy are these 26 steps we're about
to find out this could go bad or this
could go good i have no idea
all right
let's begin the head of the pizza
there's his head i've got his head his
head is right there fantastic we're
already there 90 degrees what 90 degrees
this flip this little thing but this
thing don't move
it's not moving the hell
okay
man that is um
it's only 26 steps but it is
not
that easy for a newbie like myself to be
honest with you guys and i know a lot of
you out there probably huge collectors
and have done this and you're like dude
this is super simple why are you making
it so difficult
um
there's a lot of crackling and hard
twisting and hard pressing to get things
going and some pieces do fall off along
the way of course you can't put them
back on
but it is um
i mean i remember transformers would be
a little easier to transform
this takes work
and at times you think you're going to
break it but you're not but sometimes
you gotta really press hard to lock it
in there
but i mean
outside of that
it's
pretty straightforward once you kind of
understand how it's all kind of put
together
but from what i've seen on the unicron
transformation to this of course this is
much
much easier
um but yeah this is uh this is it and
then here's uh mainframe right here
mainframe isn't that difficult to
transform because once you look at the
instructions
i mean to go from to call it the cockpit
area or the bridge
into robot mode is relatively
straightforward then of course once you
go into the computer mode that's a
little bit more convoluted which we'll
show you in just a second uh we'll speed
that portion of it up just you know for
the sake of this video
yeah i'm digging them i'm digging them
and the nice thing is
all these
markings right here the autobot insignia
all here are not decals
they are painted on
let me tell you i was a kid
we all were years ago this is the
journey of life
and when i had my g1 autobots and
decepticons
the eyes i love the eyes on this because
the eyes have got sort of this glass
look to them
so
it gives me the sense
the ark is looking at me
the frustration
to deal with decals after decals after
decals
and if you put them on wrong and you had
to take it off and put it on again and
it would all start rolling on the edges
i didn't want to go through that again
i think you can feel my pain i'm still
scarred by it
years
later the ark
it's all painted on baby
another thing to point out here is the
articulation on the hands because like
unicron where you can manipulate every
finger to your liking
on
the arc you cannot
so all four fingers move at one go and
then you have a straight thumb
four fingers
straight thumb
i don't know what he can grab
or what he can do with this straight
thumb but
it's there also the gun turrets here are
not swimmable or removable they are
locked in here so don't try to take them
out
uh so yeah
if you want to go
around the house then
you better aim
accordingly
pew pew pew
and
pew pew pew so now we've transformed
mainframe into teletran one and as you
can see right here
it's a computer
but on the back of it we do have the
discs the gold discs the bok disc and
the voyager disc which are here and very
much just
more for
the show than anything else
some
interesting transformer lore here so if
you want to find out more about these do
look it up on wikipedia there's a lot
more information on these discs
but we don't want to go too much in the
depth of them because there's not much
you can do with them except put them on
the back of teletran one so
it is what it is as i say and then we
got sky spy right here the satellites
and
you can just
play around and have them float around
or you know you can
maybe put
sky spy there maybe not you know you can
find a place for sky spy
because it doesn't fly
at least not in real life
it is what it is
so anyway that's pretty much it for
these two but
there's also optimus prime in this
package
you're probably wondering where's
optimus at is he inside of the ark is
inside the chest
is he
inside mainframe
no and no
if you can find optimus prime here
on this table
we'll give you a prize right zacky
no
no no price okay no price
so can you see them
if you can't let me help you
this
is
optimus prime
autobots transform and rule out
okay
that was sorry
wow
wow zaki wow
wow that's right man you try you try try
but zucky's got talent to add that sound
effect in
right now
there we go there we go
this is the comparison
what a setup here
the ark unicron scorpenoc
on the desk
zaki
we need a bigger desk
yes we do
we do what's up omnidesk omnidesk this
is a 1.3 1.5 what size is this that's a
1.5 i think it's a 1.7 time it's 1.7
time
just putting that out there
we are not transforming him
this took hours and hours and hours
gerald did it the last time with white
gloves and a lot of you commented that
he was really caressing
uh unicron in a very odd way
we had a discussion with gerald about
that and uh he's
accepted that he had an
some sort of fixation with unicron it's
all taken care of
um that's why i'm here because i'm not
gonna crush the ark
just not my thing
this is quite nice though
no bobby no don't do it don't do it
don't do it but let's compare actually
scale of size between scorpenoc the arc
and unicron for a second i'm going to
tell you why now
obviously this is a
more manageable size
for optimus prime
now granted this size will be too big
for the arc unicron
is a planet
in front of unicron we've got the head
and of course then we've got the little
figurines that sort of represent size of
the autobots and decepticons but with
the arc it's a little bit perplexing
because
optimus prime here on the arc
is the same size
as these autobots and decepticons here
for unicron yet the ark is a ship
and unicron
is a planet
so skill to size
slightly off
deal breaker no
but it's just something to point out
because we're here to talk about the ark
so final thoughts on the ark
this is an interesting piece i think for
collectors out there you're going to
pick it up and for the price point it
comes in much less than unicron
obviously a lot smaller and a lot easier
to transform than unicron as well
um
skill to size
it's off right i think we've pretty much
established that but that's not a deal
breaker that's just small details that
you know i mean this is a situation with
this thing is you're going to transform
it once or twice then you're going to
find it's optimal you know would you
want to be a spaceship or to be a robot
you're going to keep it that way
so
those little small things
they're not much of consequence to be
frank with you um
yeah i mean mainframe teletrain one is
interesting as well i mean it's it's
cute it's fine but this is the big boy
this is what you're getting this for
and i think it's quite interesting so
yeah i mean it's definitely a buy if
you're collector if you're just a casual
transformer uh person out there that's
like you know should i get it should i
not
you know you got to get the ogs first
you got to get optimus prime you got to
get all the you got to get the you know
megatron you got to get the guys first
then you can venture into the ark if
this is something that your collection
or your room can handle the size of this
but i always say go for the ogs first
then venture off into something like
this but if you're a collector you're
gonna get it anyway those are my
thoughts on the ark uh let me know your
thoughts in the comment section below do
you like this is this something you're
going to pick up or are you going to
just pass and wait for something else i
would love to hear from you guys on this
anyway for more information check out
our link in the description below follow
us on facebook subscribe here on this
channel and like this video it helps us
out a lot with that guys stay safe take
care and i'll chat you in the next one
[Music]
you